THANK YOU FOR STANDING UP
FOR THE RULE OF LAW THE
CONSTITUTION AND TRUTH.
JOINING US FOR MORE FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND FORMER
CONGRESSMAN.
A PROSECUTOR THATEVER LOST
A SINGLE CASE IN HIS LIFE
TREY GOWDY IS WITH US.
LET’S GET YOUR ANALYSIS OF
WHAT THE PROFESSOR SAID, THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ASPECTS OF
THIS.
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAD TO TAKE ON
THIS BREATHTAKING HYPOCRISY
AND IN TERMS OF IGNORING
QUID AND PRO AND QUO JOE AND
ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER AND
FIRING THE PROSECUTOR OR YOU
DON’T GET THE BILLION.
>> YEAH, SEAN.
I DISAGREE WITH PROFESSOR
DERSHOWITZ A LITTLE BIT.
I DON’T BELIEVE IT HAS TO BE
A CRIME.
YOU CAN SLEEP ALL DAY AS
PRESIDENT.
THAT’S NOT A CRIME.
THAT IS MALFEASANCE IN
OFFICE.
WHAT I AM PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN IS WHAT
DEMOCRATS THINK MAKES A
PRIMA FACIE OR A THRESHOLD
CASE FOR BEING ABLE TO
INVESTIGATE SOMETHING.
WITH TRUMP, IT’S A
CONVERSATION AT A DOGGONE
BAR.
THAT’S ENOUGH TO LAUNCH A
FISA PROBE INTO SOMEONE WITH.
WITH THE BIDENS, POLITICO
AND THE HILL JUST PRONOUNCED
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE.
WHO HAS LOOKED INTO IT.
IF IT’S GOING TO BE LOOKED
INTO, IT NEED TO BE BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
LOOK, I LOVE MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE.
BUT IF IT’S CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY THAT WE ARE
INTERESTED IN, IT NEEDS TO
BE LOOKED INTO BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
>> Sean: I HAVE BEEN SAYING,
THE PRESIDENT HAS A
CONSTITUTIONAL OATH.
YOU TAKE A SWORN OATH,
FAITHFULLY EXECUTE THE LAWS
OF THE LAND.
THERE IS ENOUGH PRIME FASCIA
EVIDENCE ABOUT JOE AND
HUNTER TO WARRANT AN
INVESTIGATION BY FAR.
I’M ASSUMING THAT JOHN
BOLTON IS GOING TO SAY
SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT THAT
I HEARD HIM SAY I’M NOT
GIVING HIM THE MONEY UNLESS
HE DOES A, B, OR C.
THEFOUR FACTS THOUGH YOUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE JIM JORDAN
THEY NEVER DID ANYTHING,
THEY NEVER PLEDGED TO DO
ANYTHING, THEY DIDN’T KNOW
AND THEY NEVER FELT ANY
PRESSURE.
IT WOULDN’T MATTER TO ME,
BUT I ASSUME THAT’S WHERE WE
WILL END UP AT SOME POINT.
>> WELL, WHICH IS WHY OUT OF
250 REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE, EXACTLY ONE
VOTED WITH THE DAZZLING ADAM
SCHIFF.
I KNOW THAT POLITICO AND THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" AND THE
HILL AND "THE WASHINGTON
POST" THANK GOD THAT WASN’T
THE JURY.
I KNOW THEY WERE DAZZLED BUT
THE REALITY IS ADAM SCHIFF,
ALL THESE MONTHS OF
INVESTIGATING UNLIMITED
ACCESS TO SUBPOENAS COULD
CALL WHATEVER WITNESS YOU
WANT TO CALL IN THE HOUSE
OUT OF 250 REPUBLICANS.
HE CONVERTED EXACTLY ONE.
>> Tucker: AMAZING.
CONGRESSMAN TREY GOWDY
FORMER CONGRESSMAN.
I GUESS CALLING YOU
CONGRESSMAN THAT WOULD BE